I have no choice but to admit that we
have a remarkable economic situation
right now the situation is not that we
will never again have a recession in
fact we almost certainly will unless
something changes permanently about the
type of economy that we have at some
point there will be a recession uh or
worse because that's the way that things
have worked for a very long time but
when we look at the latest inflation
numbers and we look at all of the other
data that we have it is quite an
extraordinary situation we have new
inflation numbers out today it's July so
the numbers are from June and for the
12-month period ending in June of 2023
and year-over-year inflation is down to
three percent
three percent I have been talking about
for over a year now I've been saying I
believe that by August of 23 inflation
will be down to the low fours or the
high threes which would be a dramatic
improvement from where it was a year and
a half ago
I don't know anything it was just my
sense of the direction things were going
and I actually was too conservative in
my estimate inflation consumer prices in
June Rose at slowest annual rate since
March of
2021. according to the latest data from
the Bureau of Labor Statistics now these
right Wingers who just don't like these
numbers will say you can't believe these
numbers that's not real okay well when
when you like the numbers you believe
the numbers from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics and now they'll go oh but
eggs are expensive I saw the other day
uh we don't judge these numbers by what
one person sees in one grocery store
this is actually a metric that is
extraordinarily detailed and nuanced the
Consumer Price Index went up 0.2 percent
last month and that prior year number it
is now a three percent increase a three
percent increase as of last month we had
a four percent year-over-year increase
we are now down to a three percent
year-over-year increase these are really
good numbers and it is not just
inflation in a vacuum that looks really
good and I'll come back to what we mean
when we say inflation looks good wages
are rising and are now higher than they
were before the pandemic inflation
adjusted again the detractors the the
the Maga pessimists will say well sure
nominally wages are higher but
inflation's been crazy no no no no
inflation-adjusted wages real wages are
now higher than they were before the
pandemic if you look at the G7 countries
the U.S has the lowest inflation of all
of them if you look at gas prices gas
prices are now down about a buck 50 a
gallon the unemployment rate is at 3.6
percent that is under four percent for
the longest stretch in 50 years 50 years
and of course they will come back and
they will say oh but a lot of these are
low quality jobs or a lot of people have
stopped looking for work these are
always things that can be said it's the
way these metrics work you can't only
say that when it's to your advantage
these are the real numbers now let's
talk about inflation a little bit I want
to remind you that the target for
inflation is not zero the target for
inflation is considered to be two
percent we're basically there we're at
three percent the target is two percent
so we're getting down to an inflation
level that is what you would want for
what would be considered by traditional
economic measures a good inflation
number let me remind you why and I know
that there are people who have heard me
say this before but I do think it's it's
such an important basic economic concept
to understand that I want to explain it
again if inflation is really high we
know why that's bad people can't afford
stuff if inflation is eight percent and
wages are only up two percent Things
become unaffordable so people stop
buying them which is bad for businesses
so businesses have to lay people off and
then the people they lay off don't have
money to buy things so then more
businesses have to lay people off so a
very high inflation it's pretty
self-evident why that's bad some people
might say well shouldn't we want zero
inflation or even deflation prices
coming down it'd be so great everybody
can afford what they want
wrong
if there is a deflationary situation you
would expect things to be cheaper in the
future than they are now and so save for
absolute Necessities like food you need
food to survive
if you expect prices to be lower in the
future you would delay economic activity
if I'm looking at a car and I say well
the car is going to be three percent
cheaper in six months I wouldn't buy it
and it has a similar effect as things
being unaffordably expensive which is
you're not buying and that's bad for
businesses they lay off workers and you
have the same thing the reason that by
traditional economic measures we say two
percent inflation roughly is what we
want
is that that two percent inflation is
what drives economic growth uh and
expansion now of course when we step out
of this traditional economic analysis we
say well the planet is of limited size
and resources you can't have indefinite
growth and that is also theoretically
true and in some sense it's practically
true before we get to that point we may
be off to mining asteroids or who knows
what so it starts to get a little
theoretical and philosophical but that's
the reason why a little bit of inflation
is considered good I also want to remind
you there are many aspects to inflation
that have nothing to do with the
president so I'm not here to tell you
we're going to Bow and pray at the altar
of Joe Biden that because of what we're
seeing much the same way that it wasn't
exclusively Trump's fault that inflation
was high there are many aspects to
inflation that don't relate to the
president this includes changes to the
money supply supply and demand shocks
like for example you know natural
disasters coveted whatever the case may
be
expectations about inflation become
self-fulfilling prophecies these things
are bigger than the president and
remember inflation's coming down in all
G7 countries but it's coming down more
in the United States what presidents can
do is fiscal policy like government
spending taxation Etc and indirectly
monetary policy remember the president
doesn't control monetary policy directly
the FED does but the president does
decide who is in charge at the Fed so no
reason to play political games no reason
to sugarcoat or to do sky is falling
stuff these numbers are what they are
they only slightly relate to Joe Biden
but this is a good sign overall doesn't
mean it's a perfect economy doesn't mean
there won't be a downturn at some point
in the future
one of our sponsors today is relief band
relief band is the number one FDA
cleared anti-nausea wristband clinically
proven to effectively prevent nausea and
vomiting relief band is a type of
therapy called transdermal
neuromodulation acue stimulation and in
really simple terms it's just a band you
wear on your wrist that sends a gentle
pulse to the part of your nervous system
that regulates nausea and there's been
growing research showing that relief ban
can help with nausea from motion
sickness from pregnancy and from all
sorts of other situations and a number
of studies suggest relief band can help
with nausea after surgery in conjunction
with medication many people use relief
band for nausea from anxiety or
migraines when you feel sick on a car or
plane or a boat it's simple it's safe
it's drug free and there are no side
effects relief band has an A plus rating
from the Better Business Bureau with
over 100
000 satisfied customers online it's just
a brand you can trust you can go and
read the reviews let relief band help
you make nausea a thing of the past
you'll get 20 off plus free shipping
when you go to reliefband.com and use
the code Pacman at checkout the link is
in the description